we're asked how many centiliters are in
one deca leader so the first thing we
want to do is just think about how much
is a centiliter relative to a liter and
how much is a deca leader relative to a
liter and i'll write the prefixes down
and and really you should have these
really memorized because you're going to
see these prefixes over and over again
for different types of units so the
prefix kilo
sometimes kilo this means a thousand
that means a thousand
cent if you see hecto
hecto means 100
deca
means 10. if you have nothing then that
just means one then so let's put that
there then if you have deci
de c this means one tenth
if you have centi
centi this means
one hundredth if you have if you have
milli
this means one thousand
so let's go back to what we have we have
centiliters we have centi right over
here so centiliter let me write this in
a different color if you have a
centiliter so a centiliter
centi
liter
this is equal to one hundredth
of a liter
one hundredth of a liter
or you could say one liter for every
hundred centiliters so you could also
write it like this one
liter
for every hundred
or per every hundred centiliters
centiliters
centi
liters
so we got the centimeter now think about
the deca leader so the deca is right
over here so a deca leader
deca leader
means 10
it means 10 liters
or another way to say it is for every 10
liters
for every 10 liters you will have 1
deca liter now before i actually work
out the problem what's going on here
we're going from we're going from a
smaller unit to a larger unit so they're
going to be many of the smaller units in
one of the larger ones and we could do
it multiple ways so they want to we want
to essentially convert one deciliter
into
into centiliters now we could just do it
by looking at this chart or we could do
it with the
i guess you call it dimensional analysis
making sure the dimensions work out
let's do it the first way so if you have
one deciliter so if you have one
deciliter how many liters is that well
that's going to be 10 let me write it
over here let me scroll to the let me
say so one deciliter over here would be
the same thing as 10
liters that's liters we're assuming that
our unit is liters here and then 10
liters is going to be how many
deciliters it's going to be 100
deciliters right because each of these
is 10 deciliters and you have 10 of them
so you're going to every time you go
down you're going to be multiplying by a
factor of 10.
10 100 deciliters is how many
centiliters well 100 deciliters you each
of them are going to be worth 10
centiliters so that's going to be a
thousand
a thousand centiliters so we have our
answer one deck leader is one thousand
centiliters
one
thousand
centiliters now the other way the other
way to do it is you could convert a
decolleter to liters and then convert a
liter to centiliters so if we have one
deciliter
one
deca
a liter and whenever you do unit things
just make sure that it makes sense you
know sometimes people instead of
multiplying they would divide and they'd
get oh one deciliter is equal to one
thousandth of a centimeter and they say
no no no a deck leader is a much larger
unit than a centiliter so one deck
leader has to be a bunch of centiliters
so this should be a large number so you
should always do that reality check
whenever you're dealing with units but
let's do it the dimensional analysis way
we're starting with one deciliter we
want to convert it to liters so if
you're converting it to liters you want
the deciliter in the denominator deca
leader and you want liters in the
numerator now how many liters are one
deciliter well or you could say well ten
dec 10 liters is equal to one deciliter
10 liters is equal to one deciliter so
one deciliter is equal to these cancel
out 1 times 10 is 10
liters now if we want to convert this to
centiliters we're going to want the
liters in the denominator and you want
the centiliters
centiliters in the numerator now how
many centiliters are there per liter
how many centiliters well one liter
one liter is 100 centiliters centiliter
is one hundredth of a liter notice this
and this are the inverse statements
they're saying the exact same thing one
liter per 100 centiliters here writing
one liter per 100 centimeters we've just
flipped it but it's giving the same
information and the reason why we
flipped it is so that the liters cancel
out and then we're just left with 10
times 100 is 1
centiliters
one thousand centiliters
and we are done